mr. mechanic do you need a close-up on
that there you go sir run away welcome
to Colorado 47 the latest hitman episode
has been released this week episode 5
Colorado that's in the USA and our job
is to take out four people who are
leading a little militia there's someone
who looks after these troops there's
this someone who was in interrogations
expert someone likes explosives and
there's one who's the boss as well we've
got to take them all out so the plan
today is to kill everyone absolutely
everyone a complete massacre but to kill
those four people in ingenious ways
we'll see how we go with it
so here we are Colorado that is a nice
house let's do this double or 47 make
the first kill brilliant got a block
blow up blow up but for God's sake blow
up you stupid barrel ah there we go
there we go did on purpose completely
did on purpose
what's this gen doing is he urinating
we're not allowed not allowed move on
sir another one you're an ending in
public look at the size of his weapon
flip a leg sorry dude put your bits away
right Oh a mine under a car mr. mechanic
do you need a close-up on that there you
go sir that's right run away
another one another one are what
happened something happened that
mechanic he just fell asleep I don't
know what happened dude let's see if we
can get you as well there you go
suspicious it's quite suspicious to
murder people run away what do we have
here Oh Oh an old axe we have to try and
put this in someone's head there's two
of them can we take two out with this no
we could throw it that could work excuse
me fella how'd you catch
hahaha sugar a knife knife knife oh yes
ah very satisfying very satisfying
ultimate hit man do it I've got a new
wax you want to see it
have a look among the backs ask me no
questions
oh no that's a bad joke but joke let's
see if his next guy could catch me go
fella I absolutely love the adoration
combat runaway get changed and then run
away into a box ow my dick in a box just
a dick in a bar
what have my victims looks like the guy
from is it Friday the 13th losing but
the masks youment the jacket like a
lumberjack oh wow that's quite clever I
like that I'll be back for you soon
darling oh oh wow I could be a scarecrow
looks like the gecko from bus stop
stubborn run stubborn run
tried-and-tested stubborn run off FRA
stubborn run away run away what's in
here nothing right I need to get to that
computer which he was just out then so
he's the dog Bobby's head he's gonna
noise me back just go for it just go for
it this puts explosives so we can take
out one of our targets without touching
him so we'll see if that works here he
comes
so here's a theory that red box thing
there on the left near the center of it
that is going to we've rigged so the
explosion should be further than he
expects so hopefully he shall die this
day so let's wait and see
as long as I'm blending in hopefully no
one will realize it's me who did it well
ha here we go here we go yeah one down
Sean Ross he's the leader he's down now
who's next but no one has the clue it's
me evil genius right I need to get
costume the uniform from that Shack so
how on earth can I do it well I'll
expose this wire then go up to the sink
and fill the sink and hopefully he will
stand on this I'm being electrocuted
let's see how it goes
throw something oh he's coming he's
coming
just press it recording you ready yeah
look at those moves don't see like MJ
our next target has one arm which is
pretty cool what am i doing I'm
undercover so I'm taking part a training
exercise run raging hopefully we can use
that
see they're all dead
go to the backseat and there's some
paperwork 20 seconds to go come on come
on come on come on come on faster than
that voice and then press the button to
extract yes right she's stood in front
the cow let's take her out RAM RAM to
run away
in fact walk away quite sternly I'm
trespassing Oh what do I do I'm
trespassing oh the other guys coming
just hide hello there sir a bulletproof
vest is not it screwdriver proof like a
closet door will be fat ass so we have
two people gaming how can we take these
out why are they playing not you all
right let's turn this toy on get out of
the way one then when he turns it off
they will stab him in the head stare at
it come on
thank you and good night
let's see if the other guys realize he
has not let's put him to sleep Oh Oh
Gavin tell it is chilling on the couch
where's my screwdriver oh it's in the
back of your neck sorry sir
right let's blend in let's play games
with my friend who's asleep and naked
and we are playing oh we're playing oh I
know this one
what is it the bald guy in the other guy
I forgot what he's called
Kane and Lynch there we go got there in
the end
don't run away don't run away come back
to me my pretty like I sleep on the bed
let's pull him permanently to sleep oh
wow that looks good you shouldn't go to
sleep fully clothed oh dude
there you go get my screwdriver and yes
I'll leave you to sleep no night
princess
it's hammer time
oh right just in case we knew this let's
start a gas leak and run away how do we
kill you Oh administer overdose good
night sweet prince
this is ech that's not an overdose he's
asleep that's not real man's overdose oh
well we'll come back to you later
come time oh [ __ ]
I mean blue manic Oh gross the Gothic
doctors just shooting yeah are you
here we have our victim
stubby see you Michael Myers I think we
can kill him better than that I'm not
happy with that let's try again let's do
something different
reload let make him blow himself up by
loosening the valve ha ha ha evil master
bland you shall die on this day oh I
died right let's do that again this is
what's supposed to happen I get out of
the room and then he goes boom that's
two down now I think my three down we
got the woman earlier on three down one
to go
one of my targets is just sat here by a
slurry pit it can't be this simple it
just can't be this simple it can't just
push her and be done something will
happen or will it do a killer believer
I'll just sure that was it that really
was a target Wow right got a shovel like
Stano shovel or I do like this your next
job our victim shovel cranium cranium
shovel runaway combat runaway I'm a dick
in a box I'm a dick in a box baby
no one has glue not even you orange guys
this is my house this is where
these where I know the people who try
and come upstairs sorry if that's really
offensive that's my American accent
terrible isn't it
apologies I'll work on it in future
murder whole murder murder
you must stop running for Lisa to you
soon another one anyone for another one
he's gotta be at no.1 committee stupid
to keep away around the corner over and
over Wow he can take bullets look at
that adamantium skeleton under there
let's see what's under is he's Johnny
Johnny Terminator not forced he'll get
back up soon no beer eat anyway oh my
word look all these bodies I really need
to stop murdering so many people this
chap is near my murder poodle the
electrocution poodle so hopefully he
will walk into that door let's see yeah
there he goes ready for the rib any
second now he'll stop raving here we go
spooked when the beat hits you cannot
stop dancing look at these moves right
let's ship him out the window
goodbye my fridge a branding iron yes
I'll have the branding iron right with
him using this wench wench wench even
and he's gone squash under a bale of hay
next branding-iron to the skull Oh boom
why is that so satisfying to anyone to
money we got by cashing through the
skull that was quite good that look
professional another one paying let's
blow him up
taken care of
three five two three one two three Oh
crud oh no it's all going wrong oh shoot
oh shoot three
no one saw any more one more down there
stealth down there 47 to the head ah
perfect
these two that's just our new submachine
gun yeah
yes satisfactory so the only chap I
can't kill it this one in here I over
give an overdose but it just didn't die
in this Norway and the door doesn't open
book through the best so he has to stay
alive so I'm hoping someone will find a
way to kill him because I have no idea
at all anyway it's time to leave I'm
gonna go as the Scarecrow because he
just looks so cool and we'll see how we
did
I was on this a couple of hours so I'm
expecting 200 moving severloh 130
wow it felt like a lot more than that
130 so here's your challenge if you
choose to accept it can you reach 130
kills I don't think there's any more but
I'd love to see it you can do it I'm
Adam from PlayStation grenade sweeney's
comment subscribe and watch more of this
random rubber